c'est un très bon film je pense pour les
enfants c'est drôle et ça fait un petit
peu peur en même temps c'est bien et qui
est à plaindre
pour halloween ça fait peur mais c'est
bien c'est sympa ouais c'est c'est un
bon fils pour pour pour la journée de
l'halloween on se prépare pour ce soir
tout doucement c'est bien réaliste ça
fait peur
j'avais déjà vu le 1 je suis pas déçu du
2 et je trouve que les eu les effets
spéciaux sont bien faits bohemian
rhapsody c'est vraiment très très bien
les musiques sont bons son génial c'est
queen
quand on est fan c'est c'est un super
film et même si on n'est pas femme les
fans l'histoire de freddie mercury elle
est très très très poignante très très
prenante je suis fan de rock depuis
depuis petit et que pour moi ça me
touche encore plus je pense que
enfin il ya ça qui jouent et puis il ya
aussi le fait que c'est très bien
interprétée par les acteurs ne connais
pas vraiment l'histoire de fruits des
recueils ça permet de voir un petit peu
autrement d'une autre façon et puis de
découvrir des choses sur lui deux filles
voir sa vie finalement